est ce que big boss vous regarde chez
vous quand vous êtes au bureau vos
supérieurs peuvent vous avoir à l'oeil
mais en télétravail vous avez tellement
plus de liberté un employeur pourrait
être tentée de vous surveillez à la
maison en at il le droit oui et qu'ils
n'ont pas besoin de votre approbation
pour le faire mais pour se protéger il
devrait tout de même vous avisez pour
éviter de vous surprendre dans vos bêtes
en léopard lorsque votre vie privée est
un droit fondamental
votre patron ne peut pas utiliser des
moyens trop intrusif comme des logiciels
dits prennent des photos des vidéos ou
des captures de votre écran en continu
ou pire enregistrez vos appels
téléphoniques avec des collègues ou des
clients sans votre autorisation
ça c'est carrément criminel
des vérifications sporadiques c'est
moins risqué par exemple vérifier votre
utilisation ouriel du téléphone et des
logiciels de l'entreprise si vous pensez
que vous supérieur dépasse les limites
adressez-vous à votre syndicat ou aux
tribunaux pas ses mots
[Musique]